لان ضجيج المعارك لم يهدئ في اوكرانيا
جنوبا وشرقا يسابق الاوكرانيون الزمن
للحصول على العتاد العسكري الذي يعيد به
لكن هل يسابق حلفاؤهم الغربيون الزمن ايضا
لتغيير الواقع على الارض
لقد حزم امر الدبابات بعد طول تريث وتبدو
القائمه مغريه للثياب احدث ما فيها ذلك
الذي التزمت به بولندا بتسليم 60 دبابه 30
منها من نوع بيتي 91 و 14 دبابه اخرى من
طرازيلي بارد في القائمه ايضا الالتزام
الالماني بتسليم 14 دبابه من طرازيلي بارد
وبثق ذلك العدد من دبابات تشالنجر
بريطانيا اعلنت لندن انها ستدعم كيف اما
الولايات المتحده فتخطط لارسال 31 دبابه
من نوع ابرام خلال الاشهر المقبله بينما
تحدثت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه عن محادثات مع
باريس لتسلم عدد من دبا كيلو كلير الفرنسي
وهناك المزيد
فالنرويج وفي اللاندا وهولندا واسبانيا
والبرتغال وكذلك كندا كلها اعلنت
مساهماتها بعدد من الدبابات في دعم الجيش
الاوكراني انه حلف الدبابات الكبير كما
وصف تركيا
قدرات المحدوده للجيش الاوكراني الذي ظل
يعتمد على التسليح الروسيه بما في ذلك
دبابات تي 72 السوفياتيه وهنا التحدي
الكبير فالانواع الحديثه من الدبابات
الغربيه المختلفه في انظمه تشغيلها تستوجب
نظم تدريب وصيانه متطوره لا تتوفر للجيش
الاوكراني الان
الى مدينه كولونيا الالمانيه وصلت اول
دفعه من الجنود الاوكرانيين لتلقي تدريبات
على استخدام الاليات العسكريه الغربيه
الجديده لكن الحرب لا تنتظر فقد حذر
الرئيس الاكراني فولودي ميرسي من التاخر
في ارسال الدبابات الغربيه في الوقت الذي
يخفف فيه الروسوماتهم في الجبهه الشرقيه
ويحاولون اختراق الدفاع الاوكرانيه لذلك
سارع المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي الى التاكيد ان دبابات
لبرد الالمانيه يمكن ان تصل في وقت اسرع
مقارنه بنظراتها الامريكيه التي تتطلب وقت
اطول فتح الدعم الغربي الشهيه الاخرانيه
الى درجه قال فيها متحدث باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه انهم يريدون الان
طائرات اف 16 وان العمل جاري لتهيئه
البنيه التحتيه للمطار من اجل تامين
هبوطها